hoy vamos a hablar de algo muy
importante cómo separar un país de otro
porque hay mucha gente que se piensa que
esto del independentismo solamente
ocurre en cataluña y en españa pero nada
más lejos de la realidad en el mundo hay
cientos de casos de regiones que se
quieren separar del país al que
pertenecen en europa podemos contar
decenas de ellos y hoy vamos a hablar de
los principales vamos con ellos
bienvenidos a visual politics soy
enrique fonseca y esto que veis en la
foto se llama portas buemi acá está en
la frontera entre república checa y
alemania pero esto no siempre ha sido
así antes formaba parte de otro país que
ahora mismo ni siquiera existe un país
que se llamaba el imperio austrohúngaro
después de la primera guerra mundial
pasó a formar parte de otro país que
tampoco existe en nuestros días que se
llama rey checo de checoslovaquia
yo hitler en la segunda guerra mundial
lo invadió dijo que eso sobre alemania
lo invadió y durante unos años fue parte
de alemania
cuando hitler perdido la guerra volvió
otra vez a formar parte de
checoslovaquia y hoy en día es parte de
lo que conocemos como república checa
en europa solo en europa se han cambiado
las fronteras los países han creado
nuevos países a partir de otros otros se
han juntado y hoy vamos a hablar de los
principales movimientos secesionistas es
decir regiones pequeñas que se quieren
separar del país al que pertenecen vamos
a ver de los principales porque sería
imposible hablar de todos ellos porque
hay cientos de ejemplos de países
pequeñitos de regiones que se quieren
separar solamente para que os hagáis una
idea solamente en italia hay tres
regiones distintas cada una con su
referéndum de independencia convocado
por internet con su partido político
nacionalista y con sus discursos y sus
legitimaciones en ucrania tenemos
también algo parecido está por un lado
la invasión rusa en intento de
separatismo por parte de algunos de los
que viven en dones de la población
rusoparlante que vive en el este de
ucrania si hay muchísimos ejemplos y no
podríamos dedicarnos a todos dedicar
tiempo a todos ellos así que sólo vamos
a hablar de
los más importantes os dejo con alberto
que nos va hablar de escocia si enrique
empezamos con escocia ya que no podía
faltar en nuestra vista a menudo
confundimos reino unido con inglaterra
en realidad inglaterra es sólo una
región de gran bretaña tara y otras más
también está gales irlanda del norte y
escocia
los escoceses siempre han tenido
bastante autonomía de hecho tienen su
propio sistema legal y jurídico que
tiene muy poco que ver con el derecho
inglés desde la época de william wallace
las relaciones entre la mente rey
escocia no han sido muy buenas incluso
en la política tienen sus diferencias
los escoceses votan mayoritariamente a
partidos de izquierdas mientras que en
londres son más conservadores por si
fuera poco escocia es una de las zonas
más ricas de reino unido
y es que buena parte de esa riqueza
viene por el petróleo que hay en su
territorio marítimo la ciudad que veis
es a ver bien ahí están todas las
empresas petroleras que explotan el
famoso petróleo del mar del norte como
os podéis imaginar los escoceses son de
todo menos pobres y alguno pensará que
podrían ser aún más ricos si no tuvieran
que compartir los beneficios del negro
con sus vecinos ingleses
la estrella la conocéis en 2014 escuece
como con un referéndum de
autodeterminación y nada mal lo que
querían que los que quieran quedarse en
reino unidos
sin embargo el partido nacionalista
escocés continúa subiendo en popularidad
y su líder alex salmond parece dispuesto
a hacer otro referéndum bueno enrique y
de escocia a donde nos llevamos ahora
pues si te parece alberto del castillo
de william wallace nos vamos a ir al
castillo del conde drácula que como
sabes estan transilvania que es una
región que forma parte ahora mismo de
rumanía sin embargo en la época del
auténtico conde drácula eso era una
región autónoma de lo que se conocía
como el imperio húngaro de hecho del
auténtico el original vlad tepes la del
emperador no hablaba rumano sino que más
bien habla húngaro en esta región que yo
os digo tenían cierta autonomía dentro
del imperio húngaro vivían por un lado
los campesinos y la gente pobre que
hablaba rumano y luego la nobleza y la
alta sociedad que hablaba húngaro y eran
los que se les conocía como los
de hecho por eso esa zona se la conoce
como de heiland
la nobleza un gran no es que fuera muy
tolerante no es que fuera muy pacífica
de hecho a ti alberto que te gustan las
historias un poquito de truculentas
te recomiendo que te leas algo sobre
erzébet báthory que era una condesa
húngara que llegó a bañarse en la sangre
de sus súbditas así se las gastaban los
nobles húngaros entonces volviendo a lo
que nos ocupa después de la segunda
guerra mundial con la victoria de
ceausescu el comunismo deciden que
transilvania va a formar parte ahora de
el nuevo estado romano
los rumanos parlantes que vivieran en
esa zona deciden entre comillas vengarse
y acabar con todo vestigio de cultura
húngara entonces prohíben el idioma
prohíben las tradiciones prohíben la
cultura todo lo que lo que queráis y
hace nada más una operación de
reubicación de población cogiendo a
todos los criminales ladrones gente de
baja estofa que había en el resto de
rumanía y colocándoles en transilvania
para verse así poco a poco van
disolviendo y desapareciendo y
destruyendo lo que podía quedar de
cultura húngara después del comunismo
los húngaros que han quedado que todavía
son una parte importante de la población
los húngaros y quedan en transilvania
ahora pues lógicamente odian a los
rumanos y quieren separarse de ellos
entonces han hecho todo tipo de
manifestaciones de referéndums de
movimientos políticos de todo tipo para
conseguir convertirse en un estado libre
asociado de rumanía es decir compartir
si hace falta política exterior y
ejército pero para todo
ser un estado totalmente independiente
hace que hay que resaltar que
transilvania es la zona más rica de
hungría de pronto hungría de rumanía son
donde hay más industria es una de las
zonas pues más más prósperas de la zona
y eso pues hace que también pues quieran
quieren independizarse para poder
disfrutar de su riqueza sin tenerla que
compartir con el resto del país y además
tiene una característica especial es el
único movimiento nacionalista el único
movimiento secesionista que en europa
apoyado por otro estado europeo es decir
los schleck ellis que se quieren separar
de rumanía cuentan con el apoyo del
estado del gobierno húngaro apoyo
oficial les mandan dinero públicamente
les les han apoyado ante todas las
instancias internacionales de hecho en
2014 pues sacaron una propuesta de
estado libre asociado que lógicamente el
gobierno rumano
ni siquiera escuchó ni siquiera leyó
pero que tuvo todo el apoyo del gobierno
húngaro
los dos países tanto rumanía como
hungría forman parte de la unión europea
o sea que es un tema muy complejo y
también muy interesante que seguramente
nos dará pie para otros vídeos
bueno enrique ha apuntado que ese
consejo literario pues de drácula nos
vamos con los esquimales de groenlandia
un país con el tamaño de la unión
europea y la población viaria durante
siglos groenlandia ha sido una colonia
de dinamarca los grandes es ha mantenido
sus tradiciones esquimales de forma
prácticamente intacta hasta nuestros
días hasta ahora el gobierno danés
subvencionaba todo subvencionable a
cambio tenían un multi territorio para
establecer bases militares y alguna que
otra factoría para pescadores
los inuit que es la forma en respetuosa
de llamar a los esquimales siempre han
querido cortar relaciones con dinamarca
y ser un estado independiente este error
soberanista se hacen todos los últimos
años cuando se han descubierto montones
de cimientos de petróleo gas piedras
preciosas uranio y otras mil cosas en
otras palabras los holandeses tienen una
fortuna bajo sus pies y encima son pocos
horas de partido el partido nacionalista
groenlandés arrasa siempre en las
elecciones
la última presidenta llegó a decir que
viviría para ver su país completamente
independizado después tuvo que dejar el
cargo con un escándalo de corrupción y
ahora parece que el nuevo gobierno tiene
temas más urgentes que la soberanía en
cualquier caso en unos días o más vamos
a sacar un vídeo hablando
específicamente de viboral andy así que
vamos a dejar el tema para otra ocasión
y no podíamos hablar de independentismo
en europa sin mentar el caso de bélgica
en bélgica el independentismo es casi
tan tradicional como los gofres ha
existido desde que se creó el país hace
cosa de un siglo porque si bélgica es un
país muy moderno y para que no lo sepa
es un país que está dividido en dos
es dos zonas donde se hablan distintos
idiomas en el norte hablan una especie
de dialecto del holandés que se llama el
flamenco y tiene una cultura protestante
mientras que en el sur es lo que se
conoce como la parte balona hablan un
habla francés y tienen cultura católica
esto lo que nos cuentan siempre los
medios de comunicación siempre que algún
problema alguna tensión nacionalista y
nos tienen que hablar de bélgica sin
embargo hay mucho más allá mirá este es
el mapa en este mapa se pueden ver los
resultados de las últimas elecciones
regionales en bélgica fijaros en una
cosa la parte norte es casi en su
totalidad naranja un naranja clarito
verdad bien este color clarita
representa el partido nueva alianza
flamenca que es un partido nacionalista
flamenco o sea que quieren separarse del
resto del país pero además es un partido
de derechas y republicano mientras que
en el sur si os fijáis es mucho más
heterogéneo pero más o menos se podría
decir que la mayor parte de las
provincias o de los cantones votan al
partido socialista que es un partido de
izquierdas
y si no es explícitamente monárquico es
mucho más amable con la monarquía de lo
que puede ser el partido flamenco
también allí o sea fijaros que hay unas
diferencias políticas importantes y
luego estamos con la economía el norte
es muchísimo más rico que el sur de
hecho tiene la mitad de paro mucha más
renta per cápita casi toda la industria
son gente mucho más rica y tienen ellos
tienen la sensación de que con su dinero
se está subvencionando la vida a los
francoparlantes del sur en cierta medida
les tenemos que dar la razón para que os
hagáis una idea en el norte se hizo una
vez un estudio y se contaron que había
más de
radares de control de velocidad para
estos radares que sacan la foto a la
matrícula si te pasas de el límite de
velocidad vale tenía como unos 1000 en
la parte francesa no llegaban a 50
o sea que imaginaros la cantidad la
diferencia o sea los flamencos pagan
muchísimas más multas de velocidad que
los franceses esto se puede aplicar a
todos impuestos multas etcétera con lo
cual muchas veces los flamencos tienes
de sensación de decir hollins es que os
estamos pagando la vida esto no no tiene
ningún sentido por si esto fuera poco
encima hay otro tema que no se suele
contar que es la monarquía bélgica es
una monarquía pero a diferencia de la
monarquía española el rey en bélgica sí
que tiene poderes para hacer intervenir
en la vida política es decir en españa'
ya sabéis que el rey
bueno pues ponga un cargo meramente
institucional no puede decir esta ley se
pasa esta no en bélgica sí es decir en
bélgica el parlamento aprueba una ley
pero luego el rey puede vetarla y puede
decir no esto esto no lo no lo aprobó y
de hecho ha pasado o sea no es que sea
una cuestión pues pues institucional
tradicional no es que por ejemplo en el
caso de la ley del aborto
parlamento belga voto a favor de
legalizar el aborto vamos a decir y el
rey lo veto y echó para atrás todo el
proyecto de ley y hubo que volver a
votar lo hubo que cambiar la ley
etcétera etcétera etcétera o sea que es
una cuestión muchísimo más compleja de
lo que parece
ortega y gasset decía que los pacientes
se quedan dos formas o bien juntando
varios países que ya existían o bien
separándolos el separatismo ni es nuevo
ni es único de cataluña tampoco se puede
decir que sea más o menos legítimo que
el unionismo supongo que hay que
analizar caso por caso lo que sí está
claro es que antes de opinar hay que
conocer las razones de unos y de otros y
tratar de dialogar no obstante si no
estáis de acuerdo siempre podéis aportar
vuestra opinión en los comentarios de
este vídeo